pour égayer les fêtes de fin d'année
plus de 1200 colis cours mais ont été
distribués en porte à porte à maurepas
pour les seniors de plus de 62 ans
puisque cette année coville 19 oblige
pas de repas de noël prévu comme tous
les ans gymnase ce titre on a souhaité
avec l'équipe municipale proposer
davantage de colis à tous les seniors
qu'ils le souhaitaient pour une personne
ou de personnes donc voilà on a une
équipe de plus de seize agents qui
mobilisait sur le terrain avec une
douzaine d'élus volontaires qui se
prêtent au jeu pour aller en porte à
porte auprès des seniors pour leur
remettre le colis pour les fêtes de fin
d'année
comme véronique rocher adjointe à la
culture qui a distribué ce matin-là plus
de quinze colis bon alors c'est pour
deux c'est pour annoncer pour vous
souhaiter de bonnes fêtes de pâques et
dans ce colis surprise plein de douceur
écoutez ya déjà une belle bouteille de
bordeaux au moelleux du blanc sublime de
canal jean paul ii puis des petites
confiture
un petit bloc de foie gras donc c'est
pas forcément mon job mais on a fait
appel aux bonnes volontés et je suis
vraiment ravi de pouvoir rencontrer les
morlaisiens à cette occasion là je le
fais pour la seule et d'arrêter une
solidarité attendu par les personnes
âgées qui pour certains passeront noël
sans voir leur famille